all right turning now to a very
disturbing report from Jim Jordan now
get this apparently Federal
investigators were asking Banks to
search the personal transactions of
individual Americans for terms like
Trump and Maga Banks were also asking to
see to use Merchant category codes to
identify potentially suspicious
transactions and what transactions did
treasury think were so suspicious small
arms sporting recreational Goods in
other words if you go to stores like
Dick Sporting Goods and Bass Pro Shops
by the way I got my boots for Iowa at
Dick Sporting Goods uh thank God for
instacart if you were a law-abiding
American who legally purchased a gun
after 2021 your government thought you
needed to be monitored Now sources are
telling Fox News digital tonight that
the impetus for this very serious
invasion of privacy was of course none
other then January 6th now these
Revelations should scare every single
American you want to talk about privacy
constitutional rights or do you want to
live in an orwellian nightmare nightmare
with big brother and by the way uh so
should Biden's wideopen borders which by
the way continues to have real
consequences Americans they're fighting
back the family of a 20-year-old woman
who was strangled to death by an illegal
immigrant who turned out to be an MS uh
13 gang member is now suing the Biden
Administration saying that she would be
alive today if Joe Biden enforced our
nation's border laws here was the latest
on all of this house Judiciary Committee
chairman Jim Jordan you know it just so
happens I went to uh Dick Sporting Goods
ordered from them uh boots when I was
headed to Iowa where I saw you and the
wind chill was 20 below zero um and I'm
glad that they had great great boots
great traction I'm I'm happy I went
there I want to understand this tell me
what they did here because do do we not
have privacy anymore in America uh is
this not a constitutional violation
unreasonable search and seizure yeah now
in the last year s we we've exposed the
censorship where we had big government
big Tech big media big Academia working
to censor Americans now we have
Financial surveillance where it's big
government working with big Banks big
corporations to surveil to spy on
Americans and so it was big Banks
looking and searching private
transactions using key terms at the
suggestion of the federal government to
to find out what what you're buying what
you're spending your money on scary
stuff all it looks like without any
warrant without any legal process they
undertook this as a way to identify
domestic violent extremism and here
here's here's what it sounds a lot like
remember that that memorandum in
Richmond about uh pro-life Catholics are
extremist because they go to church and
they pro-life and they talk about you
know protecting human that's exactly
what these documents sound like we're
right on the on the you know front edge
of this we'll see how it all progresses
but it's scary stuff it's Financial
surveillance of the American people all
right let's talk about um so your
committee and the oversight committee uh
went forward with contempt uh violation
against Hunter Biden Hunter's attorney
Abby LOL was seeking a new subpoena
you argued I think rightly so that you
we already gave you a subpoena you can
comply with that one uh however it seems
that negotiations are ongoing um
initially both you and James comr said
no we're not going to give you a special
accommodation uh it seems now that
you're open to one why do I suspect I
know Kevin Morris is going in tomorrow
the $6 billion million sugar brother um
do you have any Assurance from Abby LOL
that Hunter Biden won't be pleading the
fifth the whole time if you in fact give
that special
concession well we've had a good
conversations our chief counsel in the
committee has had good conversations
with Mr LOL the council for Hunter Biden
we do believe Hunter Biden is going to
come in that's what we want we want his
testimony whether he exercises one of
his privileges under our constitution is
up to him and his councel and what he
decides to do but we do expect him to
come in we're we're pinning down a date
for that but we've also got Kevin Morris
tomorrow we got Eric scharon Rob Walker
mvin Yan we got all these people coming
in in the next two weeks and then we
want to talk to Jim Biden and then we
want to also talk to Hunter Biden we
just got to get that date down but we do
um we do believe he is coming and that's
what we said in committee last week when
we marked up the contempt resolution we
said we're going to pass it out a
committee if Hunter Biden wants to cure
this and he wants to come in and we can
get the testimony from him all the
better and that's the negotiations we're
in now we think he's coming which I
think is good for our investigation our
impeachment inquiry as we move forward
you know Joe Biden seems to lie a lot we
know he lied when he said not once did I
ever speak to Hunter my brother or
anybody for that matter about their
foreign business deals then he lied to
the American people for years saying The
Border's closed and the bord is secure
everybody around him lied about that now
we know that he also lied uh we were
told that there was in fact uh an Ethics
agreement where they would never know
who the people were that were purchasing
uh Hunter Biden's art now the art dealer
uh gave a deposition and in that
deposition James coma confirmed this uh
we now learned that in fact he said no
Hunter demanded to know who the buyers
were and in fact Joe Biden got involved
and he also was talking to the art
dealer um I'm like wow is the arrogance
that high that they're getting money
from all these countries no experience
and and Joe taken official actions as
vice president that helps his son get
paid for no experience yeah and the
gallerist told us George Burgess the
gallerist told us that that was the only
contract he had with any artist he did
business with the only contract he had
which had that provision where Hunter
Biden can know and we know that 70% of
the art purchased in the last two and a
half years totally $1.5 million we know
70% of that came from a couple of
purchasers who happen to be Biden donors
donors to the uh the president's
campaign so tomorrow we're talking with
Kevin Morris who bought
$875,000 worth of art from Hunter Biden
Hunter obviously knew who that guy was
he was with him last week when when he
came into the oversight committee so
we're talking to him tomorrow we expect
to get some some important information
that will help us answers the questions
we have as we move forward in our
impeachment inquiry well apparently he
was one of the big uh purchasers of of
Hunter's art on on the top of the $5
million that had been previously
reported uh will Joe Biden be called in
do you believe that your committees will
subpoena Joe Biden at the end of this
we're going to move through the key
players that we think think we need to
get to in this impeachment inquiry as we
said Kevin Morris tomorrow next week uh
Eric shuran Rob Walker we will talk to
them then we want to talk to Jim Biden
and then Hunter Biden we think all
that's going to happen and then I think
we make a decision do we move forward
with actual articles of impeachment as
I've said many times Sean and you know
the evidence I think we have thus far is
already pretty darn compelling but it's
important we do this the right way do it
with the facts get the evidence talk to
the key people that's what we're doing
on the Judiciary Committee that's what
Mr comr is doing on oversight and of we
had the whistleblowers come through the
Ways and Means Committee all right
Congressman Jim Jordan house Judiciary
Committee chairman thank you sir we
appreciate your time as always com hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else